[Music]
we've got a bone to pick with you Abby
Lee Miller you pride yourself on
creating top-notch dancers but you never
paid Chloe much mind in your eyes she
was second best but she's so much more
than that you only had eyes for Maddie
and never hesitated to put Chloe down
well that's too bad for you because the
girl is gifted beyond belief she's
probably one of the best dancers you've
ever taught and you didn't appreciate
her until she was gone Chloe Lucchese AK
is a fan favorite for obvious reasons
she's by far one of the most talented
dancers to have ever danced at the ALDC
keep watching to find out why Chloe
deserves a permanent spot at the top of
the pyramid while no one likes to admit
it Chloe and Maddie's rivalry made Dance
Moms all the more interesting but in the
end it's just not right to compare
people to one another so are Maddie as a
star but she has a very different style
than Chloe and Chloe is more talented
than Maddie in some domains despite
being told that she was number two since
she was about nine years old Chloe
always kept fighting for a spot at the
top of the pyramid and she succeeded
more than once when it comes to dancing
Chloe was basically built for the stage
her entire looking bodies one of a
graceful dancer she has long legs and
arms and a knack for memorizing
choreographies in the nick of time on
top of that Chloe is super flexible and
able to push her body to the limits
every dancer has their strengths and
tumbling isn't something that Chloe
excels at but she's a naturally gifted
dancer who always puts her game face on
if there's one thing that proves just
how talented Chloe is it's how she
commits to the routine she's performing
when it comes to ballet Chloe is a
natural she's a beautiful soft dancer
who steals the show every single time
ballet is considered to be the core of
every dance and most dancers struggle
with perfecting their ballet but not
Chloe she's got disciplined in the bag
and she doesn't need hours of practice
to embody the beauty that is ballet
she's so talented that she was awarded
the Joffrey Ballet scholarship it's easy
to pin Maddie and Chloe against each
other because at one point in time they
were the two best dancers the ALDC
he had to offer but something magical
would happen when you paired Maddie and
Chloe up for a duet these two delivered
some of the best duets of all time and
it's thanks to them both having a very
good sense of musicality Chloe can share
a stage with Maddie without letting
herself be outshine and that bears
repeating
Chloe is one of our favorite dancers so
we totally hated it when Abby put her
down throughout the first few seasons it
was apparent that Chloe had lost some of
her passion for dance thanks to Abby of
course but if there's one thing Abby can
never take away from Chloe it's her
amazing improv skills you can put Chloe
on a stage cue the music and watch her
invent a beautiful solo on spot now
that's Talent on top of being an amazing
improv dancer which isn't all that
common contrary to popular belief
Chloe's also really good at other
disciplines she can go from ballet to
hip-hop in the blink of an eye which is
something to commiserate the Chloe's
talents don't stop there
yes she's a trained dancer but she also
has a thing for musical theater Abby
chose to broadcast Chloe's weaknesses
instead of her strength which is why so
many people see her as number two when
she's clearly number one every artist
has a dark side and Chloe is no
exception when it came to performing
dark numbers on stage Chloe was all for
it
in fact she excelled at it if there's
one duet we just can't get over it's
Black Swan both Maddie and Chloe gave
this duet their everything and it was
breathtaking
Chloe excels at playing dark characters
which isn't always an easy thing to do
we think Chloe outshine Maddie during
this number tell us if you agree in the
comments it's clear as day that Chloe
was meant to be a star she's only 18
years old and already supports herself
by being a social-media influencer
amongst many other things but if there's
one thing Chloe has always loved its
acting and she's super good at it too
Chloe has already starred in movies like
next level and loophole and she's been
cast as Devon Dupree in the upcoming
film the message clearly Chloe is just
getting started
what's most impressive though is that
Chloe managed to
of her career and excel at school all at
the same time though we recently
announced that she had been accepted
into the super prestigious Pepperdine
University only the best candidates get
accepted into this private college
making Khloe more impressive than ever
Khloe loves to read and is a mega
intellectual there's no use denying it
Khloe Lucchese AK is talented beyond
belief but it's not her many talents
that make us love her
because there's so much more to Chloe
than her accomplishments despite growing
up on the hectic dance mom set Chloe
always stayed true to herself she was
kind to others on and off the camera The
Dance Moms cast has often revealed that
Chloe was one of the nicest girls they'd
ever met which is probably the best
compliment a person can receive do you
think Chloe deserves a permanent spot at
the top of the pyramid sound off in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]